in this morning's ion money and we
certainly wish Jimmy Carter well sure do
we're thinking about you President
Carter today in this morning's ion money
we are looking at how many parents still
help out their adult children
financially it's a big club 2018 Merrill
Lynch survey found 79 percent of parents
financially supported an adult child
between the ages of 18 and 34 25 percent
said they would be willing to withdraw
from their own retirement savings to do
it for the Perry family in Tampa
financial support means allowing their
31 and 28 year old sons to move back in
with them after they struggle to make
ends meet
they pay their own cell phone bill they
pay their car insurance you know so they
pay for those things that make them
independent but the shared stuff is is
all us yes of course I could be saving
money putting it aside but it hasn't
affected our retirement or our stability
so it's something that we can afford at
this point see this is exactly where I
wanted to put mine and you did my house
burned down at one point I was in the
military bad relationship various means
and it wouldn't be where I am right now
without their help life takes whatever
turn it wants to and it's up to you to
how you deal with it and how you
perceive it that's very true
it's really not bad I mean we have great
fun as a family I don't think people
should look down on it it's just how it
is these days we believe in family and
that family should support family should
we have to do it know do we choose to do
it yes CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here to look at how that
kind of support can affect everybody in
the family Jill good morning good
morning I like what you just said it's
just how it is this day it's just how it
is these days when I was younger it was
you were almost embarrassed to say I got
to move back in with mom and dad but
it's becoming very commonplace yeah and
I feel bad this is a generation that
basically graduated from college and
also high school into the worst
recession since the Great Depression and
so what we know is when you graduate
into that kind of environment you're
ages can lag your older peer groups for
10-15 years and don't forget a lot of
these young adults we're operating under
the weight of student loans I know that
we've talked a lot about that and if
you've got thirty forty thousand dollars
of loans and it's five hundred or three
hundred dollars a month you have no
choice but to move back with your folks
Jill if the family we just saw they said
they're not cutting into their
retirement savings but if you if you are
is that advisable as my certified
financial planner background would tell
them at you please don't do this you
know really this is so this is really
dangerous because you don't have time to
make it up on the other end right and
what we really are hoping people are
doing is saying okay I can help you as
you saw in this family the Perry family
kids are paying some of the utilities
that's great I'd like people to set
goals you can stay home for this long
then we're going to try to transition
you out but don't eat into that
retirement account we have one survey
that said half of parents are actually
foregoing some of their retirement
contributions putting something like
five hundred million dollars towards
helping their kids out when they should
be putting that money into their own
retirement why is this happening it's
such a high rate in a supposedly booming
economy well again I think this really
goes back to when these kids did
graduate remember when you graduate into
a recession you might even get a job
you're lucky to get a job but what do
you do you don't argue for a raise
you're so happy you have a job I have
benefits I'm so happy I'm gonna keep
this job because I want to get off my
parents health benefits by age 26 so I
think this is a real problem
remember we treat the millennial
generation many people will sort of turn
their nose down at it we didn't do that
with the greatest generation they
actually said we dealt with a depression
and it followed them for decades
throughout their lives so when does it
make financial sense to help your adult
children those parents would say I gotta
help them I think that we make we make
sense of doing this when there is an
emergency when you need your kids to
actually get on their feet but make it
time-limited set those ground rules and
have these hard discussions all right
Jill Schlesinger thank you very much we
appreciate it ahead